if you were on a mission to fight the
legendary ninjas from hell what Would
You Do the whole country is depending on
you and this job could cost the lives of
someone you love I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the Devils of kimon in ninja
Scrolls this legendary swordsman is
going to watch the brutal death of
someone he loves jubay here is a lone
wolf Ninja for hire passing through this
town he comes across some douchebag
Samurai they try to Rob him but jubay
swiftly defeats all three in no time he
then notices a storm headed his way so
he Retreats for cover thinking this
storm ain't no big deal not realizing
that this is the beginning of the end
the next day these villagers fix up
their town after the bad weather when
they then see a woman approaching them
in the distance walking like a zombie
and covered in skin rashes she quietly
tells these people that her Town nearby
shimoda Village has just caught a
terrifying plague overnight all of her
friends her neighbors have died and now
her turn is up next she collapses and
kicks the bucket stunning the villagers
later the ruler of the town next door
orders the evacuation of shimoda village
and hundreds of people without a home
arrive at his doorstep he then gets
worried that someone saw a stranger pass
through town last night right before the
plague started there this butt ugly guy
thinks that something strange is going
on and prepares his Squad of ninjas to
go investigate thinking this Mission
will be a piece of cake that night his
finest Warriors head to shimoda Village
cutting through this Forest including
this boss babe kagera but the team
leader then notices that some of his men
have suddenly fallen behind suspicious
he tells his second in command to go
back and look for them but that's when
this guy finds dozens of his men dead on
the ground they've been murdered he
tries to alert the rest of the team but
then gets electrocuted to death by some
strange assassin his piercing screams
then alerts the rest of kagero's team
and everyone gets ambushed okay one
second ago I was sent off by my boss to
go investigate a town that suddenly got
plagued by an infection overnight which
is suspicious as hell because we have to
remember this happens in feudal Japan
and this happened at night when a good
portion of people would have stayed in
their houses the whole time anyways it's
not like the virus spread into a party
town where all the villagers gathered to
hit the club in such a short time frame
even with such a virus like the measles
which has the highest reproductive
number one person can infect up to 15
people at once having a whole town get
infected by this virus means that there
must have been one Central area where
most people would have come into contact
with it in the night which is very
unlikely but for this to have happened
it had to have been in such areas like
the communal bathrooms Town Wells or
perhaps border entrances leading to and
from the town because there is no way
that such a virus could have spread so
fast otherwise the Lord and his advisors
here should have still been able to
think critically knowing that whatever
killed the people in that Village
happened through an unknown event they
should have carefully first interviewed
the citizens that made it out alive
first traveling at night back to a
contagious village where they don't know
the full story means that this Lord and
his ninjas were woefully underprepared
even before they encountered trouble the
group leader tries to fight back and
orders his best man to do some extra
cool [__] but it's not enough and
everyone gets quickly slaughtered he
gets picked up in front of kaguro by
this green face guy he quickly tells her
to run back to their Village and she
watches him get ripped apart and the guy
tastes his blood she runs away like mad
but this demon is not done and he
catches her bringing her to this nearby
empty house but that's when he notices a
strange man hiding in the shadows green
face guy begins transforming into a sort
of horrifying monster sort of like a
really scary Pokemon knowing he's in
trouble this guy quickly impales green
face in the eye with his knife and
rescues kagura he tries to go after the
two but is stopped by man bun guy AKA
yurimaru who is under Lord ganma's
orders and he says that they have bigger
fish to fry meanwhile jubei introduces
himself to kaguro and the two get to
know each other
he's a ninja for hire and spends his
days traveling Japan getting paid to
kill she tells him that she doesn't need
his help anymore and waits for him to
leave her once he leaves she collapses
in shock still reeling from what
happened with green face guy she then
goes back to her Village and reports the
horrifying events that just happened
telling the village ruler that all her
ninja teammates have been murdered the
ruler is shocked he tells her that until
they find out what they are dealing with
he's not going to send any more soldiers
to investigate shimoda Village she must
find out who the real enemy is first and
then report back as soon as possible
later jubei finally reaches the infamous
Village but notices that it's all empty
okay well that was something it's clear
that the village Lord is definitely not
thinking clearly if you know what I mean
while he's right to suggest that kagero
should do some more digging before he
wastes sending more men realistically he
should have at least thought to provide
kaguro with another ninja or two to help
her out because according to all the
scientific data from all time Teamwork
Makes the Dream work when you have more
people to help help you out it means
that you're able to take more calculated
risks that lead to Innovation the Lord
was smart enough to not send more troops
into a [__] show of a situation if I was
kaguro I would recruit some able bodies
and directly pay them out of my pocket
to help me out since clearly The Village
Lord won't and I would only begin my
investigation during Sunrise when the
woods will likely be clear of these
monsters which will allow me to more
safely continue the investigation
because trying to head back out into a
force right now is dead on Balls to the
walls a terrible idea it's strange but
that's when out of nowhere green face
guy attacks separating him from his
sword jubei quickly uses an invisible
string to snag his weapon back and the
two go into battle he manages to slice
his hands open just as green faces
Boomerang Blade swings back stabbing him
in the face killing him instantly
exhausted that's when jubei notices an
uh old man watching him from a distance
he comments that jubei has done
something terrifying he has now killed a
monster known as one of the eight Devils
of kimon a group of eight demonic ninjas
with crazy Supernatural powers and this
is gonna cost him big it won't be long
before they come after jubay for revenge
and the slimy old man uses this
opportunity to tell him to join him but
jubei tells him to get out of his face
okay that was disgusting well this
wrinkly old nasty man just told us is
that not only are we up against a pissed
off overpowered Squad of demon bounty
hunters but we are getting hunted by the
best and most horrifying group of
hunters in this world consisting of
green face Daddy bee lover Daredevil
wannabe shadow guy Red Hat lady and man
bone guy he's second in command and the
leader kenma this means that jubei here
has now been marked for dead and means
that him ignoring old man could cost him
his life if I was jubei despite how
strange he the old man may seem we have
to remember jubei is a lone wolf Samurai
which means he has no one that relies on
him and since he's a traveler no one
could have given up his location however
this Advantage is also his greatest
weakness and means that he has no one to
help him out but the old man taking an
interest in him is probably the best
nasty thing that could have happened to
jube should he decide to work with the
nasty old man his chances of surviving
have now gotten higher the next day
still wondering about the old man jubei
takes a bath in this hot spring but
notices a baddie sitting across from him
and he gets clearly a little too excited
and he knows that this is too good to be
true he pulls his sword close and
prepares for what he knows will be a
terrifying battle it's one of the eight
Devils of kimon they've already caught
up with him tattoo bad he then tells him
that he killed their Ally green face and
now he must die attacking him with
snakes jube quickly defends himself and
barely survives but she gets away that's
when he notices the same greasy old man
from before creepily watching him in his
underwear he then reveals to jube that
he's a government rat that is on a tough
secret mission to stop the a Devils of
kimon and their boss working for the
Shogun of the dark and this Shogun wants
to overthrow the government that the old
man works for but jube still refuse and
begins walking off that's when the Old
Man reveals it Ace up his sleeve telling
jube that earlier he got cut by a
throwing star and that star was laced
with poison the old man knows what the
Cure is jubei thinks he's bluffing but
he quickly starts coughing up blood now
out of options jubei reluctantly is
forced to work with him they then take a
boat and set off on their mission on the
way old man tells him that the eight
Devils of command are being led by
someone that jubei has fought before a
man named himuro genma jube is shocked
and tells old man that he killed this
guy eight years ago chopping off his
head old man says that genma learned the
dark arts of regeneration and can now
control all the cells in his body he now
can't be killed and is back for revenge
on Japan they then reach the shores of
shimoda noticing that the air is thick
with ghosts and evoo the old man trips
down this hill and the two gets
separated but that's when the old man
realizes that someone is watching him he
quickly Dodges an incoming Spear and
disappears meanwhile jubei tries to
safely reach the old man when he comes
across this Temple and he hears someone
chanting inside and follows the sound
and just like any horror movie that is
the worst thing that you can do walking
inside he sees an infected woman praying
she tells him that they'll all soon go
to meet Buddha jubei thinks something is
up and the lady begins freaking out her
skin melts off and he gets attacked from
above it's the same Baddie from earlier
okay if I'm jubei I'm not really up
shit's creek I'm covered in snakes and
now I'm dealing with a powerful very
attractive ninja this snakey lady has
the power to possess people and can make
her snake tattoos come alive at will
what I would do differently unlike jubei
is to not be as gullible as he was to
fall so easily into her trap I would
from the get-go not have taken the fact
that we got separated from the old man
as lightly as he did because while he
may be a sleazy nasty creepy old
nuisance he's the one who is familiar
with the situation and was our only
partner who we could have used since a
two-man team was better than one jupe's
arrogance is the one trait that cost him
and it's not crazy to assume that jubei
was more than capable of tracking the
old man's location by far following his
Footprints noticing the direction that
the grass bends as the old man walked
through the grass he could have picked
up on the signs of where he had fallen
and he could have more easily located
him if he really wanted to and also
going in alone as well he rushed inside
of the temple the moment he saw someone
there he didn't even bother to check his
surroundings like he should have or to
see if this area was actually a trap
meaning that he should have acted as if
death was lurking around every corner
because it was his careless actions in
this instance contributed directly to
his fate it means that really he
deserves every nasty thing that is about
to happen to him because for a soldier a
ninja whatever he is he wasn't very
ninja she demands that jubei tell her if
he and the old man are the only ones
trying to stop them but that's when
kagero shows up and holds this demon at
knife point the demon tries to bite her
but she reveals that she's resistant to
Poise losing her patience she forces the
demon to turn off her powers and demands
to know what they're doing in shimoda
village and she's about to spill the
beans but she suddenly gets electrocuted
turning her skin into Chris speed
Japanese bacon and somehow nobody
notices the hair that's around her neck
she's been killed by man bun guy kagiro
then tells jube that she has finally
cleared her debt to him for saving her
life and tells him that she will now go
and figure out what the eight devils are
up to and avenge her old ninja Squad
jubei tells her that it's too dangerous
for her but she says that she can handle
it slimy old man that appears again and
asks for kagero to also join their team
telling her that while their goals may
be different they share a common enemy
and tells it that he has some very
valuable information on ganma and his
eight devils and knows where they could
be found so just like jubei sleazy
slimeball old man gets kage road to join
them old man then tells jubei that this
girl is useful as hell and reveals that
she's been blessed with the power of
poison anyone who tries to get frisky
frisky naughty with her will get
poisoned through her skin and die
revealing to jubei the green face would
have died by her hand anyways had jubai
not rescued her that is and they'll be
able to use this power in battle the
next morning the three go down to this
River and try to sneak closer to the
center of shimota Village not realizing
that they are being tracked there they
discovered their worst fears figuring
out that the eight Devils poisoned the
wells of this town that night and any
villagers who discovered what was really
going on was slaughtered they've tricked
the residents and made them think it was
the plague using this distraction to
cover their tracks the old man knows
something is up but doesn't know why
this Village or what the bad guys are up
to but that's when they notice a few
bees flying by and it's rather strange
but then they hear something and they go
out to look feeling weirded out but then
they spot something horrifying
approaching them in the distance coming
in fast a swarm of horrifying Hornets
charging at them and they run away like
hell okay this is insane [__] happening
right now because we're up against not
just bees but they stab you once and
they're done oh no no we're dealing with
what looks like to be Hornets which
means that they'll be able to sting us
repeatedly and according to this insect
Pain Scale the pain felt from a hornet
stung is Rich party and slightly crunchy
sounds delicious and the crazy thing is
that a hornet's sting is 50 times less
toxic than a bee sting but you've got to
imagine that getting stung over and over
again by hundreds of hornets repeatedly
is enough to make any top tier ninja
shittiest pants if I was them I would
have anticipated that entering the
village would have meant running into
some kind of trouble this is Ground Zero
where everything all started and what's
worse is the bad guy we're up against
this guy is highly intelligent he has
the ability to command an army of
hornets and judging from how he began
this attack just like tattoo snake lady
both seem to prefer starting out with
ranged attacks first which can keep them
safe but now we need to worry about the
current situation which is that we have
an army of thousands of hornets headed
straight for us in order to survive we
need to do the following we need to be
able to stop these hornets from
breathing oxygen-rich air that will be
the fastest way to stop this horde in
mass and this can be done by creating a
bunch of smoke which will subdue the
Hornets and Chase the Swarm away around
us are batches of trees which can be
seen growing and this we could use to
help start a fire and create a lot of
smoke it should chase a large portion of
the Hornets away giving us a chance to
use this momentary opportunity to run
away when the Swarm dissipates or keep
the fire going and send off one of our
teammates to find bee lover and take him
out kaguro quickly uses her powers
throwing pollen into the air laced with
poison and she tries to slow them down
but there's too many Hornets for her to
handle jubei then notices the man
controlling The Hornet's swarm in the
distance and he makes a break for it
trailing him until he leads him into
this abandoned Cottage jubei gets ready
to easily kill the guy but that's when
he confirms jubei's worst fears and
tells him that the man named genma will
meet him again soon and that shocks
jubei to his core this is the man that
jube killed before and has now come back
to life and he's now learned how to
regenerate his body and now can't die so
how does he kill him jubei doesn't have
any time to process this when B guy
attacks him and gets his back cut by the
samurai sword jubei thinks it's over but
that's when this guy reveals that his
back is home to a terrifying Hornet's
Nest they quickly begin to and he runs
for his life and jumps into the river
holding his breath for as long as he can
he tries to quickly come up with a plan
attacking bee lover Hornet guy from
below and he pulls him into the water
discovering that the horn is now trapped
within the water are trying to escape
from within big eye piercing through his
skin they quickly and very painfully
kill him jube then heads back to his
group and tells them what he's found out
about his mortal enemy genma old man
tells them that they've now attracted
too much attention to themselves and
it's only a matter of time until they
both get killed and he leaves them to
carry out the rest of his mission alone
and disappears thanks kaguro tries to
figure out their next move but jubei
realizes that he's running out of time
he finally tells kaguro about the poison
running through his body and tells her
that he has less than a full day left to
get the poison antidote or else he'll
die a brutal death big Chen kaguro is
flabbergasted but jubei then has the
biggest realization of all he remembers
that during his first night in this area
he spotted some suspicious people
passing by him on Horseback and they
were headed straight for shimoda Village
and quickly tries to to get on Higher
Ground to get a clear view of the area
and he spots a shipwreck right on the
shores of shimoda Village kagero's Eye
suddenly widen as she sees her deer
Fallen comrade at the distance the guy
who got his arms ripped off she rushes
over to help him and sees his mouth and
eyes have been sewn shut and she is
spotted by Red Hat lady jubway quickly
rushes in to save kaguro as her
teammates corpses blow up Red Hat lady
thinks they're dead and runs off but
jubei holds on to his life with his
sword string and kaguro feels shame for
being a damsel in distress and tells
jubei that she doesn't need his help no
longer but he tells her to shut it and
they pull themselves up just as they
come across their next opponent the next
devil of kimon Daredevil wannabe he
challenges jubei to an honorable fight
to the death and jubei lures him into
this bamboo forest okay this fight is
about to ruffle some serious feathers
because Daredevil want to be here just
like his name suggests he's a blind
Ronin swordsman who now uses his other
now enhanced senses to beat down any
opponent he faces and the fact that he
just held jubei and kagero off of a
cliff shows that he has insane strength
jube here picked the right spot to duel
the Daredevil wannabe as being
surrounded by many bamboo Sprouts will
allow him to distract the Devil by
overstimulating his sharpened senses
while it's a myth that blind people gain
extra senses it is true that they learn
to pay more attention to the information
from their other senses it's noted that
jubai just told kaguro to stand down for
this fight which in this case was the
wrong move I would have used kaguro's
short sword to take on the Daredevil
wannabe because while he is technically
human his senses outmatch us and he no
doubt has some sort of trick up his
sleeve to gain the upper hand on us I
mean he's a bounty hunter it's not like
he's really going to play by the rules
so why do we have to fight honorable I
say screw honor we gotta fight dirty and
here's how while ninjas back at that
period usually would have carried one
short sword at best jubei here is
carrying one long sword and the fact
that Daredevil wannabe technically held
our weapon up while we were hanging from
a cliff this means that despite not
being able to see he can probably infer
that we were only carrying one sword and
that means he's only expecting one sword
to be used in combat we can take him by
surprise by quietly signaling for kaguro
to hand us for sword before going into
battle which will allow us to surprise
attack Daredevil wannabe when he least
expects it we need every Edge that we
can gain jubei realizes that in order to
kill this Samurai he can't make any
sound he tries his best to kill him but
the devil manages to dodge all of his
attacks and now kage Rose attacks their
sight has now become their weakness
falling to the ground he quickly sets up
a fake defense position with kaguro
sword now stuck to this tree and he
tricks Daredevil wannabe and stabs him
in the chest killing him and winning the
match exhausted they go to check out the
Shipwreck discovering Footprints and
signs of cargo being dragged jubie
thinks something crashed here the night
before shimoda Village got slaughtered
kagiro then discovers that the cargo
tracks lead straight to a nearby Harbor
and they both piece together the mystery
the eight Devils of kimon wanted
something from this ship and will now
try to steal the cargo by boat Damsel in
Distress kagero is horrified and tells
Tube8 that if they don't stop them
everyone they've murdered their spirits
will never be able to rest they quickly
followed the tracks and do some
reconnaissance and they run into none
other than the old man and he helps them
solve their mystery he tells them that
the eight devils are waiting for a ship
to arrive at this Harbor that is full of
gold the ship that crashed during the
storm was likely carrying stolen gold
meant to be delivered to the Shogun of
the dark the bad guys have come back to
steal what they lost and if this gold
reaches the dark Shogun he'll be
powerful enough to topple the country's
government and will start another civil
war jube gets ready to head off when
they sense another devil nearby shadow
guy kagero tries to send a messenger
bird to tell her clan what she's
discovered but the old man warns her
that her clan is too small and the gold
is not their gold which means this isn't
their fight and they likely won't react
or even help out but she brushes them
off and sends it anyways shadow guy then
tries to attack but jube quickly cuts
off his leg and he chases the devil away
tracking him into these mountains but
then jube realizes that he's been set up
meanwhile all man leaves kaguro for one
second and shadow guy appears right
behind her and takes her away jubei runs
back to have his worst fears confirmed
kaguro has been kidnapped again and
slimy old man tells her to just leave
her to her fate but jubei refuses and
goes off to save his sexy teammate
tracking them down he finds kaguro in
this run down scary looking house seeing
that kaguro was absolutely tortured but
he doesn't see shadow guy anywhere and
doesn't realize that shadow guy sees him
though okay while it's cool that jube
did the most obvious thing that all
heroes do which is to save the damsel
into stress but really why go save her
without any backup maybe put a little
more thought into this jube because
right now he's up against another devil
of kimon and this one is scarier than
the rest this guy is a Shadow Warrior
who has mastered the ability to merge
into any pocket of Shadow he sees and is
able to possess people's minds and if
you'll notice he just got his whole leg
cut off and didn't even blink it means
that either this guy doesn't feel pain
or is a certified psycho this is why
attacking him here is not the wise move
if I was jubei I would have first asked
old man to help me out and at the very
least would have waited before going
into this abandoned house where kagero
was being helped to do all I don't know
maybe some proper Recon before heading
into their willy-nilly we had old man
with us before and him working with the
government means that he could have told
us about this Demon's exact Powers which
would have prepared us all of this dark
and shadowy as crap in here it does seem
like this place is on the verge of
breaking apart getting this demon out in
the open would be my number one priority
because while he is an expert in the
shadows his looking Powers makes me
think that his skills are more suited to
stuff and Espionage and judging from how
he attacked us earlier he's not like
Daredevil wannabe he likes to fight
dirty he likes the element of surprise
and to not be in the open I would have
first brought along a makeshift torch to
light up any dark Corners we encountered
before literally burning this place to
the ground forcing the Shadow Demon to
deal with us or to even leave the house
which would then give us the time to get
kaguro and get away before the fire
consumed the household kagero turns on
jubai and tries to attack him just as he
coughs up blood he's running out of Time
shadow guy tries to attract jubei just
as he uses the last of his strength to
throw his sword right into the devil's
chest killing him and breaking the Mind
Control he has over kagero and he
quickly passes out later he wakes up to
find kagero watching over the ship
Harbor waiting for her Clan's armies to
show up concerned she tells kaguro her
clan should have showed up by now and
begins to think that the old man was
right she walks over to jube it says
that she'll repay him right now for
saving her life again she tells jubei
that the old man finally told her how to
cure jubei by getting very very flirty
with him using the poison from her body
to counteract the poison in his body
jubei is shocked happy but mostly
shocked but he declines her offer to
save his life and hugs her because he's
such a good guy jube walks out of there
to finish the job that he started later
the boat finally arrives and the bad
guys begin loading the gold jubei sneaks
in nearby and does some Recon running
into old man he comes up with a plan and
tells old man to go nearby and provide a
distraction old man heads over to ring
the bell but that's when everyone hears
something approaching at the distance
and it's kagero's Clan kagiro then
rushes over to her Village Lord and he
tells her that they've got the whole
place surrounded but that's when evil
ninja surround to them and kaguro and
her clan prepare for battle she takes
out her sword and gets ready but
suddenly gets stabbed in the back by her
Village Lord jubei freaks out and the
village Lord transforms into genma he
says that the village Lord has been dead
for days already raging with anger jubei
charges in and slices and dices every
evil ninja he sees while man bun guy
tells genma to get on the ship to meet
the Shogun of the dark man bun guy
prepares to handle jubei and lures him
into this house and manages to choke
Juve with his electric hair jubei begins
to suffocate but man bun guy falls into
Red Hat Ladies trap killing him this
lady was in love with man bun guy but he
treated her like [__] off-screen so she
took her revenge on him right here and
now getting on the boat Red Hat lady and
genma set sail ojube runs to find kagura
in her last dying breath sheet she tells
jubates that she's fallen in love with
him he was the only one in her life who
treated her like a human being and she
plants a big one on his lips instantly
curing jubei of his poison sickness he
then takes her headband that she gives
him and she dies classic anime style
okay this is so sad because kaguro here
died doing what she loved Ninja [__] she
did everything wrong possible and didn't
act like no proper ninja I ever saw she
time and time again didn't listen to
jube when he told her to stay out of
trouble and this cost her her ultimate
demise at this point all we can do is
carry on her memory with us being the
ninja that she could never be because
she useless and I'm not being funny
because Studies have found that people's
brains when in love have activation in
areas of the brain and this is why the
feeling of strong attachment love can
come with mood swings Cravings
obsessions and Distortion of reality and
this explains why kaguro was acting like
a little girl that was always hot and
cold towards Juba and also kept coming
back to jubei even when he told her not
to and this also makes sense as to why
she sent a messenger bird to her clan
she should have just gone back to the
clan herself to deliver the news if I
was kagero I would have been highly
suspicious of my clan coming here to
begin with as the old man was right
about our clan it's small the gold is
not theirs and shimoda Village has
little to do with them and after losing
their best warriors in one night it
wouldn't make sense for my clan to
divert precious resources to fight a
battle that they have no dog in she
should have recognized this fact she
should have waited in the shadows and
stayed out of sight to see what moves
they would have made first before
revealing herself she also should have
just left her lover boy to begin with
jube this punch to take kaguro's death
as a cautionary tale and leave this
whole fight himself because at this
point aside from being promised to get
paid in Gold by old man he has nothing
to do with this conflict either he's not
poisoned anymore the old man doesn't
have any real hold on him in reality so
why does he have to carry on this
Mission we know the reason why that love
is the most underrated and worst
addiction one can have jubei takes a
couple of anime seconds to be sad before
he goes back into cool guy mode getting
on his horse he chases the bad guy ship
down and swims the rest of the way onto
the boat meanwhile ganma meets with his
boss the Shogun of the dark this man is
the most powerful evil guy in Japan and
congratulates genma for a job well done
but that's when genma stabs him in the
back telling the the Shogun that he'll
steal the gold and use it to organize
the most powerful ninja army in the
world and take over Japan himself
throwing the Shogun of the dark into the
water nearby jubei finally sneaks onto
the ship taking out these ninja minions
while old man runs into red hat lady but
old man manages to one up her pouring
oil onto her he tag teams with jubei who
sets her on fire burning her and part of
the boat instantly killing all of the
Ninjas Bill kill style he reaches genma
the man he killed five years ago he
attacks him but quickly finds out a
genma is now a God among men jube gets
the [__] kicked out of enginema tells
him that he'll make jubei suffer like he
did and jubei manages to retrieve his
sword using his string and cuts ganma's
arm clean off but he realizes that genma
is Unstoppable and unkillable and juba
resorts to close quarter combat just as
the roof above them begins to fall
enraged by kagaro's death jubei doesn't
stop and stabs ganma and cuts him in
half in the blazing fire the Gold's
nearby melts and begins to form an Ever
Rising liquid metal ocean around them
and jubei tries to get to higher ground
but Gemma grabs onto him in a final move
chubei cuts his hand off and watches
genma fall into the sea of melted gold
all around him sinking to the bottom of
the ocean after Old Man shows up and
continues to be a d to jubei telling him
that he'll pay him for helping him out
only if jubei cheers up though but he
tells old man to buzz off chupe leaves
the ship and continues on his ninja
Adventures forever regretting the one
time that he turned down true love but
what did you guys think about the video
let us know what you like about and what
you didn't like about it and don't
forget to like subscribe and also check
out our how to be playlist